the world needs bridges have you ever
thought about what it would be like not
to have any it's hard to imagine a
civilization without bridges because
they're so essential for growth and
development of human society but they're
not just about a safe way across a river
or an obstacle they shout about
connectivity community they reveal
something of our creativity our
ingenuity they even hint at our identity
and when bridges fail or destroyed in
conflict communities struggle
development stagnate people suffer even
today there are over 1 billion people
living in poor rural communities around
the world that do not have safe
year-round access to the things that you
and I take for granted education medical
care access to markets which is why
wonderful organizations like widgets of
prosperity will bridges in this kind of
place this is in Rwanda and they make
such a difference not only to those
lives immediately around the bridge but
the impact of these bridges is huge and
they read the spreads over the whole
community far far away
of course bridges have been around for
an awfully long time the oldest ones are
stone because it's a very durable
material I I didn't write you I love to
look at the development of technology to
learn about what people did with the
materials and tools available to them at
the time
so the ponder go in the center is a
wonderful example Roman aqueduct in the
South of France fantastic piece of
technology built using massive stones
put together dry there's no mortar in
those joints they're just dry stone
joints fantastic and almost as good as
new today or sometimes up in the
mountains people would build these
suspension bridges
turn across some dizzy Canyon using a
vine in this case this is in Peru this
is using grass which grows locally and
is woven into ropes to build these
bridges and you know they build this
rebuild this every year because of
course grass is not a durable material
so this bridge is unchanged since Inca
times when bridges can be symbols of
their location of course Golden Gate is
Sydney are well familiar in muster the
bridge was synonymous with the name of
the place and and to such an extent that
in the war in 1993 when the bridge was
destroyed the town all but lost his
identity until the bridge is
reconstructed and bridges are enormous
features in our landscape not just
enormous
sometimes this more and they are really
significant features and I believe we
have a duty to make our bridges
beautiful thankfully many people do
think of the stunning Meo viaduct in the
South of France french engineer michel
villager and british architect lourdes
foster collaborated together to produce
something which is a really spectacular
synergy of architecture and engineering
or Rabia Maya's soggy natto bridge high
up in the mountains in Switzerland
absolutely sublime or more recently
Laurent neighs beautiful and rather
delicate bridge for Tintagel castle in
the UK these are spectacular and
beautiful designs and we need to see
more of this bridges can be considered
in three convenient categories depending
on the nature of the structural systems
that they adopt as their sort of
principle support so bending of course
is the way a beam will behave so beams
in bending or compression is the
principle may way of operating for an
arch or for the really long spans you
need to go light weights as we'll see in
a minute and you use tension cables
suspension bridges and the opportunity
for variety is enormous engineers have a
fantastic scope for innovation and
ingenuity in developing different forms
around these types but
technological change happens relatively
slowly in my world believe it or not
compared to the changes that happen in
mobile phone technology in computers in
digital technologies and so on our world
of construction the changes seem
positively glacial and the reason for
this can be summarized in one word risk
strata engineers like me manage risk we
are responsible for structural safety
that's what we do when we design bridges
like these I have to balance the
probabilities that loads will be
excessive on one side or the strength
will be too low on the other side both
of which incidentally are full of
uncertainty usually and so it's a
probabilistic problem and we have to
make sure that there's an adequate
margin for safety between the two of
course there's no such thing I have to
tell you is absolute safety contrary to
popular belief zero risk doesn't exist
Engineers have to do their calculations
and get their sums right to make sure
that those margins of air and society
expects them to do so which is why it's
all the more alarming when things like
this happen I'm not going to go into the
reasons for these tragedies but they are
part of the reason why technological
change happens quite slowly nobody wants
this to happen clients don't want this
to happen on their projects obviously
and yet of course they want innovation
innovation is vital it Ferengi as an
engineer it's part of my DNA it's in my
blood I couldn't be a very good engineer
if I wasn't wanting to innovate but we
have to do so from a position of
knowledge and strength and understanding
there's no good taking leap in the dark
and civilization has learned from
mistakes since the beginning of time no
one more so than engineers some of you
may have seen this film before this is a
very famous Tacoma Narrows Bridge
collapse in Tacoma Washington State 1940
the bridge became known as galloping
gertie because she she is a bridge
female I don't know
she was wobbling like this for
a long time and noticed this twisting
motion the bridge is far too flexible it
was designed by a chap called Leon
moseph no stranger to a suspension
bridge design but in this case he pushed
the limits just that little bit too far
and paid the price
thankfully nobody was killed but this
bridge collapse stopped suspension
bridge development dead in its tracks
for ten years nobody thought about doing
another suspension bridge there were
none and when they did emerge in the
1950s they were an understandable
overreaction the sort of over safe was
what response to what had happened but
when it did occur in the mid-60s there
was indeed a step change an innovation a
technological step change this is a
seven bridge in the UK notice the
aerodynamically streamlined
cross-section in the center there it's
also a box which makes it very
torsionally stiff that twisting motion
which we saw that Tacoma would not
happen here and it's also really
lightweight and as we'll see in a moment
light weight is really important for
long spans and everybody seems to want
us to build longer spans the longest at
the moment is in Japan it's just under
2,000 meters one span just under two
kilometers the akashic iuq we're
currently working on one in Turkey which
is a bit longer and we've designed the
Massena bridge in Italy which is just
waiting to get started Construction one
day who knows when I got to come back to
Messina in a moment but the other kind
of long span bridge which uses that
tension
principle is the cable-stay bridge and
we see a lot of these in fact in China
they're building a whole load of these
right now we're the longest of these is
the bridge in Vladivostok Russia
just over 1,100 meters but let me take
you back to this question about long
span and lightweight this is using
Massena bridge as an example the pie
chart in the center represents the
capacity of the main cables that's what
holds the bridge up the capacity of the
main cables and notice that 78% of that
capacity is used out just holding the
bridge up it's only 22% of its capacity
that's less than a quarter is available
for the payload the stuff
the bridges there to support the REA the
railway the road and so on and in fact
over 50% of that payload of that dead
load is the cable on its own just the
cable without any bridge stick if we
could make that cable lighter we could
span longer right now if we use the
high-strength steel wire available to us
we can span practically speaking around
about five or six kilometers if we
really push it but if we could use
carbon fiber in those cables we could go
more than 10 kilometers that's pretty
spectacular but of course super spans is
not necessarily the way to go
everywhere they're very expensive and
they've got all sorts of other
challenges associated with them and we
tend to build multi span when we're
crossing a wire destory or a sikh
crossing but of course if that sea
crossing was somewhere like to brought
her or in this case the Red Sea we would
indeed be building multiple super long
spans and that would be something
spectacular wouldn't it I don't know
that I get it I got to see that one
finished in my lifetime but it will
certainly be worth waiting for for some
of you guys but I want to tell you talk
about something which i think is really
exciting this is a multi span suspension
bridge across very deep water in Norway
and we're working on this at the moment
the deep water means that foundations
are prohibitively expensive so this
bridge floats this is a floating multi
span suspension bridge we've had
floating bridges before but nothing like
this it stands on floating pontoons
which are tethered to the seabed and
held down so pull down against those
buoyancy forces and in order to make it
stable the tops of the towers have to be
tied together otherwise the whole thing
would just wobble around and nobody want
to go out want to go on that but I'm
really excited about this because if you
think about the places around the world
where the water is so deep that nobody
has given a second thought to the
possibility of a bridge or any kind of
crossing this now opens up that
possibility so this one's being done by
the Norwegian roads the roads of
administration but I'm really excited to
know where else will this technology
enable development that
growing together that building of
community now what about concrete
concrete gets a bad name sometimes but
in the hands of people like really rich
yachts it here look what you can do with
it this is what we call ultra high
performance fiber reinforced concrete
it's a bit of a mouthful ice engineer's
love those kind of words but what you do
with this this is really super-strong
and it's really durable and it's got you
can get this fantastic sculptural
quality who said concrete bridges are
dull we could talk about all sorts of
other new technologies and things which
are going on robots and 3d printing and
AI and all of that but I want to take
you back to something which I alluded to
earlier on our bridges need to be
functional yes they need to be safe
absolutely they need to be serviceable
and durable but I passionately believe
they need to be elegant they need to be
beautiful our bridges are designed for a
long time we tend to design for a
hundred years plus they're going to be
there for an awfully long time
nobody's going to remember the cost
nobody will remember whether it over ran
a few months but if it's ugly
or just dull it will always be ugly or
down bridges Beauty enriches life
doesn't it it enhances our well-being
ugliness and mediocrity does exactly the
opposite and if we go on building
mediocre ugly environments and I believe
we're becoming numb to that stuff if we
go on doing that it's something like a
large-scale vandalism which is
completely unacceptable
this is
this is a bridge in in Lyon France which
was procured through a design
competition and I think we need to start
talking to those people who procure our
bridges and our structures because it's
the procurement which is often the key
design competitions is one way to get
good design but it's not the only one
but there's an awful lot of procurement
going on
that is absolutely prejudiced against
good design so yes technology happens a
bit slowly sometimes in my world but I'm
really excited about what we can do with
it whether it's saving lives in rural
Africa or stretching the boundaries of
long span technology or just crossing
the road next door I hope we continue to
build elegant and beautiful stuff that
save lives and build communities thank
you
[Applause]